okay it's a little close what do you
mean it's a little
close it's the whole point I want you to
enter my
mind plane Air Sky soaring through the
heavens coming to an uninhabited Island
full of volcanoes I think we should be
careful about the volcano thing because
what if some big disaster happens like
the day that you put the video up and
people get hurt there's no such thing as
volcano
know I don't know if that's any better I
think maybe we should start over I want
you to enter my
mind it's so full of thought and vim and
vigor I had a whole volcano thing to go
with this what am I
wrong okay I I really want to do the
Ender my mind thing they're now two
layers deep into my mind and they're
about to go a third layer in all right
Inception yourself you're trapped in my
mind forever it's a moment of stretch to
Eternity here and that's just how it is
I bought a bunch of candy from Iceland
and I brought it here with the express
purpose of doing this which is a review
of their candy now I'm not 100% sure if
all this is authentic I asked the person
there if it was authentic Iceland candy
but at the same time our our guide
wasn't from Iceland either and I don't
know if it's real so anyone from Iceland
and even those who saw me in Iceland
while I was there hello
again if you betray me on
this if you betray me you will never
Escape The Maze of my
mind you will
never you will never ever escape I just
feel like that interest is unusable what
lixian is amazing you got this right
lexian lexian you can you can make this
good right and short and quick cuz you
know retention time am I
right L wait where you
going I am Mark and I am here to review
some candy there is nothing else to this
video and there's nothing you need to
worry about these candy is from
[Music]
Iceland I don't know what's going on I
don't know I got I was thrown off [__] I
but I don't want to start over because
Ling's probably already put work into
this
and
stop how's my hair I can't see it didn't
you miss doing this huh didn't you miss
doing this I think we're out of practice
I'm doing great first
candy
it's
Zola T Zola
it's not as appealing as I thought it
would be oh that's much better it looks
like a rice krispy Bar with chocolate on
top of it which probably has caramel in
[Music]
it that's not
bad I like that a lot the question on my
mind is is this authentic Icelandic
candy so want to do is I'm going to have
a board on here if I think it actually
is from Iceland and true to Iceland and
has Icelandic Roots which I went to a
museum and I didn't see a single piece
of candy in that museum but it is pretty
good tastes like a Twix bar that has the
caramel in the center underneath the
crispie so there's like this crispy
layer chocolate with Rice Krispies on
the outside so it's got a double crunch
feel to
it it's actually very good I like that a
lot uh I give it a um an eight
and I think that it
is does isand have cats I didn't see a
single cat when I was in Iceland based
off that and because there's a cat on
the package I'm going to guess that this
is not actually Icelandic next piece of
candy
oh
heart
like got Fran Grand candy from grandma
is probably what that means because it
looks like the kind of candy that
grandma keeps in a dish not my grandma
my grandma is
Korean not a liquor protein but it's got
licorice or it's licorice flavor I'm
willing to bet that this is probably
authentic
so as you can see by the colors there's
two flavors going on here and that's why
my Expressions were shifting so rapidly
there's raspberry and licorice now I'm
not the biggest fan of licorice I like
it I don't love it and francen
confector sure sounds Icelandic and
given the fact that this flavor palette
is slightly unique not that Icelandic
dishes were all that strange I know they
have certain dishes like a a lamb's head
and and various other things but I'm
willing to bet that this is actually
iand is that the Swedish
flag uhoh is that the Ser F I don't know
my Flags well enough to confirm or deny
that
but maybe it's not but I already said my
decision so that's going in the
Icelandic
pile I don't like it five four and a
half can I this I'll eat
it
next
triter Jad got v l a talo all right so
yeah it it's little people the oh my god
did you get the art you seeing
that that's terrifying like the red one
there just the
face so a lot of uh from what I
understand a lot of Icelandic history is
a little bit dark you know a lot of dark
fairy tales for children are full of
death and despair and dismay and you
know you're not going to make it past
six kind of a language in there um so
this kind of fits and I would believe
that this is uh authentic but
I'll
W the
candy I'll let the candy speak for
itself oh my God that is so scary that
is a monster that's
scary
H it's different than I was expecting I
was expecting something sweeter it's not
as sweet as candy as a gummy you would
expect because I think a gummy like in
America is basically just sugar that's
been jellified this is uh well that was
a red
one it definitely has more lemon in it I
like that better than the red one I
don't know what the red one is honestly
there's something else I'm detecting
here though
that's good what was with the red one
maybe it hated me maybe I just ate some
soul of something horrible anyway not
bad I bet probably very authentically
Icelandic and I don't hate it I'd give
it a six it's not my favorite type of
gummy I don't know what the red one is
green is good yellow's good I give it a
seven actually just for those because
2/3 of it I 6 and a half 6.66 repeating
cuz two-third of it I like the red one
not so much not bad though
oh
now this I just got cuz I thought it was
funny um this is a Jerry can which is a
hilarious way of saying gas can of gum
gum bubble dust sneaky bubble dust very
sneaky so my understanding is that this
is
probably probably gum that's in more of
a powdery form which it is I don't know
how that makes gum better exactly I
imagine that this invention was probably
a result of manufacturing leftovers so
when you have manufacturing of any kind
of scale you end up with a an assembly
line basically of various stages of food
production and when you have shaped
candy you end up with trimmings no
matter what you probably end up with
trimmings leftover shavings stuff like
that I wouldn't doubt that this is the
trimmings at the bottom of the conveyor
belts that they scooped in to a can I
might be wrong about that if I'm about
to be sued but that's my conjecture just
an opinion waste is bad it's a good
thing is this
food could you call this
food doesn't even say what how many
calories are in it they don't have
American food safety standards well
should I eat it then
n
[Music]
I might found my new favorite
candy never mind no I didn't so when I
eat gum I eat it by the pound basically
I just shove gum in chew it for like 2
minutes it's done when the flavor is
even starting to go it's gone this
flavor does not last very long the
initial hit was nice because in its
powdered form it like really coated
every area of my tongue and was able to
like punch me in the F in the
F punch me in the face with flavor it's
from the UK though I know this because
from the back it says it's from the UK
but I'm going to I'm going to go Rogue
on my bet the
overunderish is the odds are like a
million to one if I actually hit this I
can retire so I'm going to bet that's
the Icelandic candy next
candy oh uh this is a licorice roll of
some kind I don't know what the middle
flavor is
uh so it does not unroll it's not really
an unrolling type why did I do that it's
not really an unrolling type so don't
think of it that way the dark part is a
Licorice and this is some kind of
filling so it does crumble to pieces
I've had this before spoil boiler
alert it is good though because I'm not
a huge fan of licorice but I do like
licorice uh to some extent and this is
actually a very sweet one this is
probably the sweetest of all these
candies so far even more than this I
would say actually not that sweet it's
very salty I have noticed that there's
like definitely more salt in a lot of
these than you would think however
whether or not it's
Icelandic you can't really see anymore
I'm willing to bet it's not unless it is
miss
[Music]
it oh
man oh
man not I bet that's not the the thing
is it might come from any number of
Nordic countries as well just because I
can't read what's on the package on the
floor doesn't mean that it's
automatically islandic could be Swedish
could be Norwegian could be
Dutch I don't
know oh
chocolate
peppermint Chocolate and Peppermint okay
the packaging makes me think that it's
well it's got an address on here I won't
look
packaging makes me think it's
local now I'm going to tell you that
does not look that appealing and I don't
know if I bite into this if it's going
to break my
[Music]
teeth don't bite into it I'll try
again
mhm I was about to say it's not bad how
do I unpack this it has essence of
chocolate it's chocolate esque but if
there's one thing I definitely don't do
is brush my teeth and then eat a bar of
chocolate I've done that before actually
many times that's why I'm so familiar
with this experiment that's what it
tastes like cuz there's mint right and
then inside of it is chocolate and I bet
I'm not supposed to bite it but I do not
have the mental fortitude or the
discipline to be able to hold back from
that so I'm not going to be that person
and I'm not going to change who I am for
this candy which is not from Iceland I'm
betting four five four
H whoa let's give this camera a chance
this camera doesn't get enough
love why is this camera here is it even
doing anything so this is Taris peber
from
fazer too hot to
handle so oh there's a fire on it so
apparently it's spicy but I've had spicy
things before I know it's been a while
but I do I do I open so terribly uh so
yeah it's got a fire on it it's charcoal
black and it says too hot to handle but
much like AirHeads they kind of oversell
the spice
so again licorice as far as heat
though
maybe in the
center it's not
spicy there's something in the center of
that
I can't I I can't even place what it
tastes like it's licorice on the outside
and then as soon as I bit into it there
was something that was like semi solid
it wasn't like gummy or anything but it
was it wasn't liquid either I don't know
what it was it just ruined everything I
don't know why and I don't know how but
I was enjoying the Licorice and then I
bit into it and everything went to [__]
taste like I can't describe what funny
word it doesn't have a flavor really
it's just it just tasted like
chemical it was suddenly I bit into it
and then chemical there's no way there's
89 G 72 g of sugar in
this this does not taste sweet at all
like it depends on if you consider
licorice to be sweet because among the
different candies licorice does not rank
high in terms of Sweetness in my mind
unless you're eating a Twizzler and
that's not real licorice anyway um it's
good uh but can't lie to ourselves just
like this can't lie to itself about
being too hot to hand it's not the heat
that's a
problem it's everything else about it I
hope that's nice not Icelandic I hope
I'm just going to say that I hope that's
maybe it
is maybe you know
what maybe it is maybe it's more
insulting to say I hope it's not
Icelandic Noah
oh I've been looking forward to this one
so uh it's a whistle it's a Melody pop
and I got it just because I felt like it
and if you've never had one before
you're the same as me cuz I've never had
one before so why the [__] am I so
excited about this got take the
whole oh it's a slide
too oh and it's even got little note
markings on it is there a world's best
Melody candy
player
for
[Music]
that's much better than I originally
thought I was just finding my melody
legs spit oozing out of the front of
this I don't know about that one guys
anyway flavor's all right novelty great
nine out of 10 this is great this is
probably the bane of parents existence
but pretty cool concept I'm actually
surprised that it has you know uh note
markings on it that's pretty impressive
uh great attention to detail it's a fun
little trick horribly annoying for
everyone around it but uh hey I I had
fun you should come up with a jingle
that can play between each candy you're
[Music]
right
good all
right not Icelandic though
probably are these nipples is that is
that
nipples they look like nipples do you
kind of
nipply
that's that's a straight up nipple right
there do I bite the nipple off of it or
what do I
do I'm more mature than I
look
um
uh at first I thought licorice but then
the licorice was overridden by styrofoam
and I'm not exaggerating that felt like
I bit into a packing peanut and it
tasted like it too I thought there
wouldd be a differentiation of flavor
between this darker side and the pink
side I couldn't
tell two for two sides and two nipples
anyone that doesn't have exactly two
nipples you're special and I love
you the
fre super salt hockey puck is that what
to said
hockey Pulver apparently it's like a
salt-based candy so a lot of these
flavors are based in like salty candies
that aren't normally salty in my palette
and hockey pucks it is
it I I don't
know that
is yeah that's that that sure does look
like it's just
salt
oh would you
like try
it is a purely unidentifiable flavor
it's making my mouth water so bad yeah
and what is that I don't know
ingredients
soccer ammonium chloride
lacritz
pver s o c k e r ammonium chloride is an
interesting ingredient don't usually uh
consume a lot of ammonium by
choice that's probably Icelandic that's
probably
Icelandic oh oh thank you oh my god
thank you I actually I think I bought
two of these because they looked really
good and I wanted to eat one and I think
we had some already and I know is good
so I needed a pallet cleanser really
badly because this has been kind of a
trip of flavors that I was not prepared
for there's that it's round candy I
believe that it has some it's like some
candy coating shell over some delicious
interior it's like a chewy gummy
interior but the kind of gummy that just
like melts away very sweet a little
tartness to it this is right up my alley
I I like and I know it's bad for me but
I like that kind of dextrose based candy
and I know it's terrible for me because
it crashes my blood sugar and it's
probably terrible for your body well God
I love it I grew up with that stuff big
chewy Sweet Tarts whole things of pixie
sticks oh that was my jam these are
great highly recommend what do they
called
May pinballs probably not Icelandic
though so I'm going to put in the knot
pile very good though I would I would
eat the whole bag nine and a half
nine so here's the thing there's is a
super set locris bot here given that
this has the word super salt I really
hope this doesn't taste like this I
really
hope oh what is this it's got bulbous
nodules I like bulbous nodul it just
looks like a chocolate bar
bar I've been deceived before it looks
like a chocolate bar doesn't it it
really
does
ball so the thing is I think I got all
the chocolate and I didn't get whatever
that
is oh it's just like some gummy thing
it's weird that it's in a chocolate bar
but only to me it's like some gummy
thing yeah that's my favorite kind it's
like chocolate covered gummy bears
yeah M pretty good oh it's licorish it's
chocolate covered licorice it's got
little bits of licorice in it I couldn't
tell what it was cuz chocolate like such
a strong flavor I bet that's Icelandic I
mean it could be any like I know
licorice is popular in like some
Northern countries I don't know which
ones or why but to that they
are
opal citru o salt L
[Music]
Chris did this say salt Chris no lacis
bar salt licorice lacas means
licorice we're learning already open up
for
me I'm
rich I'm willing to bet one is Citrus
one is licorice so there probably should
be no surprise in this
one
I am not surprised that's salty licorice
a little saltier than the others though
it's gummy they're not hard I don't know
why I'm excited about that it tastes
like he left a gummy out for a very long
time it tastes like a very still this is
actually not good I'm liking it less by
the second I don't I don't want that in
me
anymore let's try this one
you know what I just
said it wasn't
hard that one
was there is something in that that as
it starts to phase change you know turn
from a solid to a liquid I
I can't Jesus Christ that's very um not
good it actually grew repulsive I think
this is Icelandic just judging by the
box I guess um because I remember when I
went to the museum there were a lot of
boxes of like packaging from Iceland
that they had and it looked a lot like
this so like the color scheme the the
bright pattern colors box was there it
might have actually that had no candy
yeah and so this might actually no no
way well it did it had boxes that
doesn't mean there was candy
there yeah but this looks like actually
one of the boxes that I saw in the
Icelandic Museum so I'm going to guess
it's actually Icelandic and probably
anything with this color pattern maybe I
determine if the ones were chewy and the
ones were crunchy no it's just they're
both rock hard but they I bit into that
one sooner than the other one because I
let that soak in a little longer it did
grow softer as the
saliva got in
there I've hope this is just mint I
really hope that's just mint I've been
burned so many times in the course of
this video on things I think I'm going
to like and I
don't
please
God open
up oh my God
no no I don't need them I don't need
them I got this it's all a matter of
technique right it was all a matter of
technique so far so
good no one suspecting flavors
yeah I think it's just I think it's just
mint I think it's just what exactly what
it looks like not the sweetest mint I've
ever had but it's good I like it again
the packaging suggests to me that it
might been local but because I don't
think that was I'm going to Bo I'm going
to hedge my bets I'm going to hedge my
bets well actually no cuz this is not
native to Iceland this concept I believe
would be anywhere but Iceland right that
must be right the the idea of this red
white white stripe kind of minty candy
probably not from
Iceland I just thought I remembered
something from the Icelandic Museum yall
think I don't remember anything or learn
anything I remember this they had weird
packaging there how weird in this
triangular pinched at opposing side so
you'll notice that this one is pinched
from the vertical and then the other
side is pinched horizontally which
creates this funky like picture to this
I saw a lot in the wax paper packaging
the cartons in the museum as well it
looked like that and it stood out to me
that and that haunted
mask put up a picture
don't that's
horrible
anyway I think it's Icelandic I'm going
to put it in Iceland you want something
you're going to like or probably not
like I don't know I don't know
anymore you bought it all I know
supporting local business all right cat
cat there's no cats in Iceland we've
already figured that
out it looks like licorice let me see
the uh sorry I was a little eager so uh
looks like licorice it's jool FL filter
Lois Med CRA mly
Salia
verude what the
[__] what the
[__]
[Applause]
what the [__] that is the single
saltiest thing I have ever eaten I'm not
joking something I don't know if that's
just salt but it like was really hitting
the salt receptors I love salt let me
I'm just saying that to get a baseline
of how salty this tasted and how
shockingly salty and let me tell you how
much salt I eat when I go to the movie
theater I ask them to put the Flavacol
that they have the orange salt that they
have into a separate cup so I can dip my
popcorn individually into that cup of
salt this is saltier than that and
that's literally just salt well and some
flavor chemicals
Amy just be careful did you eat the
whole thing
no she's going like
this I know right that is that possible
I don't know right it's the saltiest
thing I've ever tasted I know no you
could grind a salt shaker into my mouth
and it wouldn't be that bad exactly
exactly you can eat literal salt which I
do I how would you eat a whole piece of
that oh my God how' you eat a whole bag
of this you could grind salt into your
palm a thing I do regularly and lick it
straight it would not be as salty as
that it's not just the coating it's the
filling as well is also extreme L salty
and again ammonium chloride which is
it's a salt sodium chloride is a salt
potassium chloride is a salt ammonium
chloride is probably what that is which
is a different type of salt salt refers
to many different things I hope that's
good for Me Icelandic for
sure oh is this tubble gum it's a pallet
cleanser thank you so much Amy for
balancing it all out cuz this is what I
need right now is this just liquid
gum what's going on there no safety seal
no safety seal no actually that is
concerning actually it didn't even twist
off this
just this was in a candy shop that a lot
of people go in and out of um and I'm
not saying like there's something
horrible put in here but the fact that
this was not sealed kind of leaking and
um
it's why is it why is it twoo differentt
why I'm not going to eat this and it's
for reasons of food safety there's a
very specific reason why food is you
know in sealed containers and bags and
stuff like that um and it's for both
give it a squeeze
though that
it I'm also not going to eat it because
all this this is making me think is this
is a tube of pre- chewed gum and maybe
this was sealed there's something in
here that says twist and maybe that is
the seal and it looks like that but I
don't know that I twisted it I didn't
hear any clicks I didn't hear any
breaking plastic I don't trust that and
I try not to eat things I don't trust
not too often uh this is definitely not
Icelandic no palet cleanser for
me it's
fine
[Music]
Raa so yeah it's uh proudly made in
Iceland that could just be a marketing
thing it looks like a candy bar just a
regular chocolate bar probably has some
wafer kind of crisps
inside please be away for
Cris
please
no it's like some nougat
caramel no it's
not it's
licorice
no now there is some kind of nouy
caramel in there but there's also
licorice there's three things in here
because I got threes all over it
chocolate caramel Li proudly made in
Iceland mhm
I'm afraid because it looks a lot like
these but it might not be can't judge a
book by its cover and that's what that
cover looks
like you want to know what it
is do you really want to know what it is
write in the comments if you think you
know what this
is am do you know what this is a
licorice is a salty licorice no it's
candy coated licorice it's actually
pretty okay I like it but it's just like
so much licorice I I I don't mind this
this is pretty good I know I didn't give
a rating for all these but you can make
up your own rating and then I can tell
you how wrong you were when you guessed
it
I not bad if I was in a mood for a lot
of licorice go to Iceland I know I said
that one wasn't Icelandic I'm also going
to say that this one is not
Icelandic just because I already hedged
my bet with the split vote on the other
thing oh boy it's the same company so
these are Turkish pepper hot and sour
again that said
hot and it wasn't hot I don't even know
what it was this says
sour I don't know what that means but
they got a flame on them and they look a
lot like these these are the new ones
this is the dark one same shape
different colors maybe fruity try the
blue one I usually like the blues or
blue
raspberry
I have good news it is not blue
licorice I have bad news it's full of
the same thing that that one
was I don't know what you are I don't
know what you are but you're not hot
what do you mean hot the outside was
like maybe a little tart I wouldn't call
it sour but at least it was in the same
field what are you what what is in you
I'm up I can't even crack it
open I don't know I don't like
it I don't like it I wish I did I wish I
did um it's just like it's an
unidentifiable flavor I don't know what
it is it's not hot so there's no heat
about it and there's Flames there's
flames on the candy I have no idea what
they're talking about it doesn't feel
like it's actually even close to what
the packaging is trying to say the only
danger is there is that there's a flavor
in there that just like tastes repulsive
I don't know if it's just me probably
not probably not me it's
Iceland next do you think Cho want candy
no can't have candy where's Mark where's
Mark Chico uh wiggle your no leg body
over here come here girl hi are you a
good girl you good girl you very good
girl what's up here she C candy cuz she
just went to the dentist yeah you just
went to the dentist you can't have candy
good girl good girl good girl yeah go
play just wanted her to say hi yeah
she's there her new legs are coming in
nicely I'm excited about these ooh this
is
a
thing frisia sour UFO tongue
painter have you ever had one of these I
think like it looks familiar but it
feels like a piece of Styrofoam I don't
know when I would have had this but it
looks familiar the two sides make me
afraid because of the combo flavor thing
going on here probably anything that has
like the stripe pattern I've noticed
like a theme if I look at these two
piles there's definitely a theme of like
Stripes going on here so except for this
except for my cherry can of bubble gum
[Music]
powder I think I think we got to take a
little
intermission get
out this next one I think we need a
drink for and watch oh uh uh uh oh
God the paint my tongue tastes like
Styrofoam has something sour in the in
the middle that actually is sour not my
favorite though I'm going to guess not
Icelandic Ed watch the editing prowess
of lixian as he materializes the drink
[Music]
right you said I needed a drink my no
you said I needed a
drink I thought you were G to you know
what do you want I don't know I think we
just with this I think all we have is a
light beer okay so this is a lacas zor
Apollo loas uh it's a licorice straw and
you're supposed to drink through it so
it's exactly what it sounds like it's a
straw of licorice which if you've ever
used a red vine to drink something this
is similar to what that probably is
however much firmer now watch the
editing prowess of lixian as he makes a
drink material lies
here milk no give me the athletic light
hey maybe this will come out in time be
perfect sponsorship for that all
right
wow that was something
special just in case this video actually
is sponsored in the right moment for
this to
occur
[Music]
this this is not real beer well Define
real it's non-alcoholic beer I'm not
going to die if I drink this it's
totally fine probably not the combo for
this licorice
straw but
hey
YOLO [__] but
hey but hey it's just a theory a food
Theory hi P you want some beer yeah I
don't know if this is the right thing
for this but it is
um it's what I have
so honestly I can't even taste of
licorice it just tastes like I'm
drinking beer through a straw which is a
very strange
thing yeah I can't really taste anything
besides the beer so you don't get some
Love Camera how you doing you keeping up
there doing a great job really proud of
you sticking in there I know we don't
use all of your shots probably don't use
much of anything but hey you don't know
glad you're there you're really coming
in clutch for the shot say
necessary but as far as like the straw
itself
[Music]
goes
I mean it's licorice it's extremely
hard like Rock Solid licorice I'd rather
eat this candy coated piece of licorice
if I wanted licorice I don't think it
added too much of the flavor of this
that I was
drinking but I could beat the [__] out
of this can with this
licorice oh freck anyway true
blue
Iceland last
one oh my
God would you look at that if that
isn't literally the most expensive thing
I saw in the store you know me big dick
money bags I think this is actually made
in Iceland please
oh no no it's not that I don't think
it's not made in Iceland I just read
what actually was in it cuz it looks
just like
chocolate you want to know what it
is you want to know what it
is know what I paid like 50 bucks for a
jar
oh my God
that is fantastic it is chocolate
covered licorice don't get me wrong but
but of all the licorice here I've had
that's amazing the licorice isn't hard
like traditional it's not hard like this
but it's not hard even like that it's
like caramel like it's soft and it's
chewy
it's it's really good that's not a joke
there's nothing about this that I'm
exaggerating and maybe it's just because
I've run this Gauntlet of licorice
that's really good because the chocolate
actually is complimenting the texture of
the licorice it's working together it's
actually like combining into something I
don't know what the powder is on the
outside it must just be like chocolate
dust or something like that I can't
really taste it or if it if I am tasting
I can't identify everything kind of
Blends together when you chew it very
good that's really good uh yeah so um
favorite least favorite oh um well I
mean actually unironically this is my
favorite hey stop stealing the show
maybe this should have been that camera
you know maybe this should have been for
over there a little late for that no no
no no so we'll just keep that over there
all right so uh to close this video out
I would say this is my favorite least
favorite was this salty hell this was so
shocking but I will give it credit I
have never felt that an intensity of
Sensation from Flavor alone it was like
someone put a hot brand and on my tongue
and it was not
fun Amy went for it again I'm going to
choose to do this delightful chocolate
covered licorice I really like this but
that's just because it's right up my
alley the chocolate bar at the beginning
here was honestly a great start I
hesitate to say it went all downhill
from there but it was just a good very
good bar this like same as that just
ammonium chloride I'm not really about
that everything else was pretty good it
just depends on how much you like
licorice if you grew up eating nothing
but licorice which is not really a
staple of American candies and again
Twizzler and even red vine is not true
licorice red vine has more licorice
flavor but even so it's like unless you
grew up with it you probably wouldn't
like it as much but a lot of these if
you grew up with it you'd be like hell
yeah give me all of it this is fantastic
crafted by
atchara atchara thank you Iceland thank
you everyone for watching thank you
Henry and thank you Spencer thank you
chica thank you Amy thank you to the
shop where I got this candy I can't
remember the name have a lovely day and
as always I will see
you in the next
video
byebye